april 2013 two bombs go off at the
finish line at the Boston Marathon three
people are killed and hundreds have
their lives changed forever almost two
years after the attacks the physical
scars here where the blasts hit a pretty
much gone but the memories are still raw
and they're going to get dredged up all
the more during a trial that could last
for several months I wish it was over
that's how I feel about it I just it was
a horrible horrible time it'll be a
necessary unpleasant experience for the
city to live through but we'll jahar
tsarnaev get a fair trial as he faces
the prospect of execution critics doubt
that it's even possible to select an
impartial jury Harvey silverglade is a
prominent civil rights lawyer he points
out just how many people were affected
by the attacks in some way ruling them
out as potential jurors there are the
people in the race there were the people
who were there as cheer the people in
the race they were their friends and
relatives of those who were injured
which is quite a few by the time you're
done with these chains and waves you've
got an enormous number of people in the
community but that's not the only
problem almost all of Boston was
affected by the traumatic manhunt that
followed the bombing many was subject to
lock downs one police officer was killed
and thousands of people feared for their
lives tomorrow we are slow khals if
they'd been affected either by the
bombings all the lockdown it was
horrible man it was just like having to
like deal with like not being able to
leave your house because you're afraid
like something's gonna happen to you
like you might end up somewhere next to
the sky I couldn't be a juror in this
because uh no because already in my head
he is guilty here because the trials the
more people we spoke to the more it
became clear that it will be very hard
to find jurors who were completely
unaffected
by everything that happened that's why
the defense called for the trial to be
moved to another city altogether but
this Joe Harvey silverglade has no doubt
the judge should have moved the trial I
would say the number of problems are so
enormous that it was no way he was going
to conduct a fair trial there is no way
he's going to be able to conduct a fair
trial even if he thinks he's got an
impartial jury but the judge disagrees
and he's pushing ahead with jury
selection here at Boston's courthouse
he's invited 1200 candidates to take
part and a very high security will soon
find out if lawyers on both sides can
find 12 jurors they're happy with